and welcome back to Hannity here is part
two of my interview with Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu you didn't Israel did not
start this war you did not want this war
but you must win the war I would argue
that let me ask you about what has been
going on worldwide and that is virulent
anti-Semitism that I never thought Mr
Prime Minister I'd see in my lifetime
you know hearing over and over again in
New York and in London you know from The
River To The Sea which means to wipe
Israel off the map or the call for anata
um I the things I'm hearing in the halls
of Congress in my country or college
campuses in my country or what we're
hearing in Europe or what you know I
never thought Australia we'd ever hear a
chanting uh gas the Jews F the Jews um
with all of that how do you it's
inexplicable to me can you can you
explain it and can you explain why the
pressure is coming from even my own
government government our government
here in the US Joe Biden to put a pause
as you now try to you know you you are
in a battle for your survival you know
never again as you said is now never
again is right
now well I think the American government
and and President Biden have been very
supportive of Israel there was a
question of humanitarian uh I I think
they were very clear we can't have a
ceasefire we have a ceasefire it means
uh that it's a surrender to Hamas it's a
surrender to terrorism it's a victory
for the access of Terror that doesn't
mean that we can't give you know in a
specific time in a specific place for a
safe Corridor for Palestinian civilians
to leave the zone of fighting yeah we do
give them the ability to do that but I
don't think anyone argues for General
ceasefire that's not going to happen by
the way the only time we'll have a
ceasefire is for the return of our
hostages without that it's not going to
happen and then we'll continue until the
battle is won but I I have to tell you
that you talk about anti-semitism I I
think that it's it's the oldest hatred
you know it's it's an old disease and in
morphs it takes on new forms every time
and what the anti-semites don't realize
is the attacks start with the Jews on
the Jews but they never end there that's
what happened in the Holocaust people
said oh well you know the attacks of the
Nazis on the Jews before World War II or
even the beginning that's okay no it
wasn't because it Afflicted all of
humanity all of civilization and that's
what you have here too the reason
they're attacking Israel is this AIS of
Terror understands that we're the Ford
position of the West and of civilization
and it we're just a a stumbling block on
the way to you so these people who are
demonstrating in in the uh in uh the
United States and the West I don't think
they represent the majority of the
American people I know they don't but
there's a a major a minority there that
is completely misguided uh and even
worse than that uh and I think that they
don't give Israel the right fight that
they would afford to any of their
countries imagine the United States as
it with
2911 Sean that's what we had
proportionately we had
291 imagine 50,000 Americans killed in
one day imagine 10,000 Americans are
taken hostage in one day imagine this
brutality this savagery in one day and
think about what would America do well
it would do exactly what we're doing it
would go against the terrorists it would
fight them in the streets it would fight
them everywhere they meet and that's
what you did against Al-Qaeda after 911
that's what you did against Isis you
didn't relent you didn't say well
because they're hiding in civilian areas
in mosul or in fuja we can't fight them
you sent your brave Soldiers there and
they did exactly what we're doing and
we're doing it in the best way that we
can but we have to win this fight and
those who don't understand it you know
that's that's a it's an indictment you
know it's an indictment of uh of uh of
these people that they are basically
aligning themselves with evil against
good uh evil cannot win and we're not
going to be impressed by these
demonstrations we're going to do what's
right and win this war for our sake for
the sake of humanity and civilization if
you extrapolate out Israel's population
uh of a little over 9 million and the
US's population you you are right you're
you're talking about in a single day
over 40,000 Americans lost in a single
day if we extrapolate out the population
on 9911 we lost
2,977 Americans um I know you can't
comment on it I want to just clarify you
are open to some potential uh deal for
the release of the hostages uh I know
there's been talk that maybe former uh
Prime Minister Tony Blair could be part
of that
negotiations and to you know there's a
lot of pressure being brought to Israel
it's not Israel Israel has gone to Great
Lengths by dropping leaflets and sending
text messages telling innocent people to
get out and here's where the safe zone
is so you you're almost giving away your
your your own intelligence and your own
you know strategies and doing so um but
you have done that but yet it's Hamas
that has been using for for a long time
now uh innocent civilians as human
Shields and they do it now and they
build their Terror tunnels my
understanding is you have found them
under under hospitals you know under
hospitals command posts in hospitals
terrot tunnels under hospitals uh
everywhere you see so I you know I said
okay let's build alternative hospitals
let's build field hospitals I've asked
country I've asked France to send in a
floating hospital ship uh they're doing
that I've asked uh uh Arab countries and
others to build field hospitals so we
can get all these people out we have a
humanitarian safe Zone in the Southeast
southern part of the Gaza Strip we put
putting in uh trucks humanitarian you
know drugs uh medicine rather food water
that's what's required under
humanitarian international law we're
doing all that and guess who's
interfering with that guess who's firing
on the Palestinians who want to leave to
the safe Zone Hamas so the fact that
people are condemning Israel is absurd
you know I'll give you the example the
best example I can give you is the Nazis
attack the West you know they conquer
Europe they conquer Poland they invade
France and so on and America and its
allies uh organize themselves to
Counterattack they invade Normandy they
go through the cities of France they go
through the cities of Germany until they
reach Berlin and reach the Victory and
in the process the German Army is
fighting them within cities they're
fighting them within civilian
communities so what do the Allies do do
they say well we can't do anything of
course not they try to minimize civilian
casualties although many many many
Germans were killed as you know and they
do the job that's what we're trying to
do we're trying to to minimize civilian
casualties but under no circumstances
should we be blamed any more than the
Allies should be blamed and those people
who demonstrate against Israel are are
basically lining up with the forces of
Darkness Chancellor Schulz of Germany
was here and he said these people are
not only uh worse than Isis which is
what President Biden called him he said
they're the new Nazis so these people
are basically lining up with the Nazis
against the allies and that's the battle
we have here the axis of Terror the axis
of Darkness against the Allies the
Allies for peace the Allies for
Prosperity the Allies for normal life
and I ask and the majority of Americans
understand this they understand who are
the forces of good and who are the
forces of bad they're lining up with
Israel most of the American people
clearly the American Congress the
American uh president and the American
Administration and I'm telling you
because they understand this is a battle
this is our common battle our battle is
your battle our fight is your fight our
Victory is your Victory and nothing can
stand uh in the way of total Victory any
more than you could have partial Victory
against the Nazis you had to win partial
Victory against al- Qaeda you had to win
partial Victory against Isis you have to
win Hamas Isis has to be defeated these
modernday monsters have to be defeated
and we will defeat them I want my last
question I want to uh I know your time
is very very limited here but you are
open to a potential deal for the release
of hostages one and number two even
though Joe Biden has said very publicly
he's calling on you for a pause that's
is that not happening even though he
said he did say that himself last week
no we we came to we came to a clear
understanding I think there's a a clear
difference between a general ceasefire
which we would only do for the release
of the hostages and again it would be a
temporary one and after that we'll
continue the battle to its final
culmination of Victory uh and I
distinguish that from uh local pauses or
local humanitarian corridors that we
make to enable people to leave the zone
of battle so we're doing that we're
actually I think have an understanding
on that but more importantly I think the
larger understanding is this you know
this is not a minor battle between two
tribes this is not a minor battle
between uh you know this point of view
or that point of view this is not what
we're talking about this is a battle for
the future of uh the future of
civilization because this kind of
barbarism that many believed was a relic
of the past has come full force in the
21st century and we see that the the
these darkest forces that take us back
to the Middle Ages and maybe earlier
periods are just as rampant and you know
history doesn't give us an automatic uh
uh guarantee it doesn't say that the
good will win over over the bad if the
good doesn't muster its resolve and
courage and is committed to to uh
winning and that's what we're committed
to and I expect that all Americans who
hear us now who understand this to back
Israel many of them do the great
majority do I appreciate it and I I
think that the once we achieve that
we'll create a better future for
everyone for us for the Palestinians for
the Middle East a future of Hope a
future of a normal life not a future
that is dominated uh by these monsters
who will uh who break every Norm of
humanity and who take us back to the
darkest periods of History we can't
allow that we have to move forward not
move back to the Dark Ages that's what
we're committed to and we'll achieve it
with God's help and with the help of the
American people and the help of of uh
Freedom loving people and civilized
people
everywhere yeah and by the way that was
reflected in AR Ras from poll today uh
in support of you um was almost two to
one uh Mr Minister God speed and yeah uh
may God uh bless you in your Victory
because you're right this is a battle
for civilization Mr uh Israeli Prime
Minister uh Benjamin Netanyahu thank you
sir for your time thank you Sean and God
bless America God bless Israel amen hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else